this secretly filmed footage from a jail
in Ghana reveals what goes on behind
prison walls men share facilities that
can hardly be called toilet hashish use
among the inmates is frequent one room
is stacked with corpses these images
were all filmed by an undercover
journalist his name enlasa DeMaio on us
is widely known throughout Ghana but
hardly anyone knows what he looks like
he's one of the finest journalists we
have in this country he investigates and
he tries to bring out the truth he will
disguise himself he can consider as a
lady he could come tomorrow I see most
likely could come Denise Diaz even a
madman he was caught to receive an hour
back
I know if you ask him that he came to
play the hour or no because the person
that came was a female should be walking
here I would he know I will never know
him but I know he's always around an ass
receives us in his office but we will
not show his face because he's made a
lot of enemies my journalism is hinge on
three principles naming shaming and
jailing so when I put this evidence
together I go to the court of law and I
testify before the courts and the bad
guys are jailed an ass assumes false
identities and uses a hidden camera this
footage is from the port of Tama Ghana's
largest with this method he is managed
to expose numerous corrupt officials
I do what I do because it rates
corruption of the society and make the
society a better place his revelations
end up on front pages of major Ghanaian
newspapers many people have been
prosecuted or fired from their jobs as a
result an ass has been honored with
numerous awards but there's a price to
be paid for his undercover work
it makes your private life a bit boring
because you cannot do what other people
do you can't go out and mingle as other
people do because of the security
implications my kind of journalism is
very risky it comes with all the traps
and threats and everything but I must
say I don't do this work alone
I do it with a team yes I lead it but
there are many names behind that means
the work possible and God his work has
also won recognition beyond Ghana
meanwhile an ass has embarked on an
international covert mission there's
still much to be done